the pennsylvania republican senate
primary is right now the hottest
political race in america the ingram
angle is doing its part to make sure the
nearly 26 percent of voters who say
they're still undecided less than a week
before the election get the chance to
see the candidates for themselves now
last night in our retaking america
series we profiled cathy barnett and boy
is the gop oppo on her flowing then
there's dr oz we have our issues with
him but he has an open invitation to
come on this show as well but tonight we
turn to dave mccormick who also finds
himself near the top of the heap in
pennsylvania dave great to see you
tonight why are so many voters uh six
days out i know there's already mail-in
ballots coming in and there's early
voting but why so many still undecided
well listen i'm uh thank you for having
me laura uh i'm uh traveling across the
state meeting every day and
pennsylvanians are so focused on this
they're angry they feel like their
country's slipping away and they're
zeroed in on the candidates and
and i think that's a great thing and
they're looking for someone who can go
fight for them in washington and they
look at me as someone who's battle
tested served in the military grew up in
pennsylvania created jobs and i feel
momentum on the ground when i when i do
these meetings and i think you're going
to see over the next few days that uh
undecided electorate is really going to
begin to zero in on who they believe can
lead the fight in washington and i
believe that'll be me yeah the the
senate uh has now agreed to lift trump's
tariffs on china we have a 400 billion
dollar serp
deficit with china on trade uh this year
that's what it's it's looking like it's
going to be dave what about the tariffs
will you vote would you support lifting
the tariffs on these chinese goods when
they have reneged on their promise to
buy 200 billion dollars worth of our
agriculture
no i would not support lifting the
tariffs and i would be a leader of a
strategy and a posture with china that
would even go beyond what president
trump did and as someone who
is uh sort of spent nine years of his
life fighting communist ideology
negotiated at the highest levels of our
government against china and then did
business around the world no one has the
experience i have to go toe-to-toe with
china and that's why you have a bunch of
strong voices on china like mike pompeo
uh like ted cruz like bob lighthizer who
spearheaded president trump's policies
endorsing my campaign we need someone in
the senate who really has the experience
to go toe-to-toe with china and i have
that well the you know the criticism of
you dave has been that you're in the
pocket of china i know president trump
came hard at you uh in that rally with
oz uh last week and and you say to that
because i know you like trump so what
gives yeah listen i'm i'm a big
supporter of president trump you know
i've spent uh my life serving our great
country in the military at the highest
levels of government and even president
trump knows that uh he asked me to be
his deputy defense secretary so i think
my credentials is someone who's strong
on china or beyond dispute and i've done
business around the world like president
trump had done in russia and in china
and that experience is going to make me
a much stronger senator and i know
better than anyone that we need to have
a strategy that goes toe-to-toe with
china the economic risk and the national
security risk are significant and we
need to have a posture that really
brings american leadership to the world
and changes our relationship with china
and i can be a leader on that dave what
do you think barnett's surging i mean
you got you and oz are two big dogs for
the longest time then suddenly this
woman pretty no one knows much about
just suddenly it's like in the top three
what's what's going on
well listen she she's getting her day in
the sun but i think what voters are
asking themselves and this this race is
so important laura you know this better
than anybody but they're trying to find
a candidate that a
has their values b can win
the general election this race could not
be more important and then can go to
washington and fight for an america
first agenda and uh and so those are the
tests that every candidate has to go
through that's what we're being
scrutinized on and kathy's
i've gotten to know her on the campaign
trail she's got a great life story but
she's been tested even the last two
years she ran for congress and lost by
20 points
we can't take a risk on this seat we
have to win this seat and uh and we have
to go head-to-head with john fetterman
right the stakes are so high yeah
republicans got because they cannot lose
this they just you just can't you can't
take a risk now dave just breaking
moments ago biden's interior department
they just announced they are cancelling
planned oil and gas lease sales in the
gulf of mexico and alaska's cook inlet
very briefly your response to that just
broke
was it's more of the war on energy it's
been a disaster for our country a
disaster for pennsylvania it's killed us
economically it's sacrificed our
national security and it's hurt the
environment and it is it is beyond
dispute that the biden policies have
failed we have to have energy dominance
we can lead the world in energy it's
great for pennsylvania it's great for
our country and as the senator from
pennsylvania this would be my number one
agenda item because this is the key to
unlocking the potential in pennsylvania
which is which is really remarkable yeah
the steel industry in pennsylvania all
those workers they need someone who's
going to fight for them dave we're going
to be watching this very closely we
really appreciate you joining us thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else